with us in studio is author producer and
casting director Bonnie Gillespie Bonnie
specializes in casting sag indie feature
films she writes a weekly column
entitled the actor's voice on show facts
com bonnie has also written several
books entitled casting cues a collection
of casting director interviews self
management for actors getting down to
show business and acting cues
conversations with working actors
welcome to the film courage studio miss
Bonnie Gillespie welcome bond thank you
thank you both for having me I
appreciate it to see some of Bonnie's
work please visit cricket feet calm
somebody's basement calm your actor
nba.com and Hollywood happy Aaron calm
so let's start out where did you grow up
I grew up in Atlanta Georgia okay and
when did you realize that the corporate
925 world wasn't for you I don't know
that I ever actually experienced the
corporate 925 world I was a kid actor so
I always knew I wanted to work in the
arts I thought it was going to be on
camera on stage and then when I moved
out to Los Angeles I I quickly learned
that writing was going to pay the bills
a lot better than acting which is weird
because being a full-time writer you
know being a self-sustaining writer in
the entertainment industry is actually
sometimes harder to do than being a
working actor so I was very lucky that
that that turned out to be true for me
and getting into casting came through my
writing because I interviewed over 250
casting directors for my column in
backstage west back from 99 to 2003 and
and so in interviewing all these casting
directors I kept man this is a really
cool job I like these people I like what
they do it's not at all what I imagined
when I was an actor I always saw the
casting directors the obstacle between
the actor and the role and it wasn't
until I started interviewing these folks
that I realized oh not at all these are
people who are on your side they're
fighting for you they're excited to show
you to producers and and that's when I
started opening my mind to other ways
that I could work within the industry
other than on camera I moved out here
twice so let me let me answer that
question on two levels one is when I
moved out here in 93 what fueled me was
ignorance
I was young I was fresh out of school I
was sure that like you know since I
could do it in Atlanta I could do it in
LA and I just moved out here and said
well great it should just be the exact
same experience except bigger and and I
was not at all prepared for the level
jump that comes from working in a minor
market where you know you may do a
couple industrials a few low-budget
indie films or you know occasionally
non-union commercials things like that
versus coming out here where they're
producing series television studio films
it's just completely different level so
ignorance is what drove me when I was
out here in 93 when I moved back out
here in late 98 I realized that what was
going to make the difference for me was
research and really checking out
everybody that I wanted to work with and
and that's sort of what self-management
for actors became it was how I could
have succeeded as an actor if I had only
had this book but I didn't so here I'll
give it to you guys and it was it's
basically a game plan for all the
research required to build decades of a
career in this industry rather than just
showing up and saying well I'm here I've
got headshots I'm you know mildly
talented hire me which is sort of how I
approached it in 93 and tell a lot of
people approach it they go down here I
think people still approach it that way
yeah enter self-management for actors
let's hope that is you know breeding a
new group of people who are better
prepared or at least more prepared for
the business side of things because you
know craft is a given your assumed to be
baseline very talented to move out to
Los Angeles and attempt a career as an
actor but then if you also have a little
bit of business savvy and know how to do
targeted marketing and really research
which projects are the right fit for you
and start building relationships from
even before you move here thanks to
social networking it really can make the
difference in your career starting
quickly or never starting at all at this
level I'm curious even though the book
is geared towards actors I mean have you
gotten response from producers and
filmmakers that say you know I love this
book and I gained from this book
absolutely yeah it's it's actually been
picked up as a textbook in film
departments not just in acting
departments but in film departments at
universities and colleges worldwide it's
one of those things where people are
saying this is the there's a class that
will
lot of film schools offer that is a how
to work with actors class and they're
using it in that as a way to like here's
how to wrap your brain around the
experience that the actors are going to
have not just on the craft level so yeah
I've also gotten feedback from people
who aren't even in the entertainment
industry saying this is just good
business sense this is good marketing
this is good good common-sense way to
run your own small business whatever it
may be so that's pretty cool no because
I sort of came across that realize we
did research for this interview and I'm
sort of turned on to this book and I'm
heavily interested in taking a look at
this one this is film courage we are
live in studio with casting director
Bonnie Gillespie what drives you what
what keeps you going day after day ah
it's just so fun you know I I think I
think people take for granted how dang
cool this gig is that we've got like the
fact that we get to work as storytellers
and that that goes for whatever your
role is in the filmmaking process it to
be a part of the storytelling process is
so cool and there are people who okay I
don't know any filmmakers who sit around
fantasizing about what it would be like
to be an accountant I know a lot of
accountants who sit around fantasizing
about what it would be like to work in
Hollywood you know we've got a dream job
no matter what part of the job is ours
whatever our role is in the
collaborative process it's really cool
and so I think what drives me I think
what gets me fired up every day is that
I am living my dream I and my dream
keeps recreating itself it's not like I
grew up saying oh I'm going to write for
actors and you know create casting lists
and and work with independent filmmakers
on low-budget Indies and cast things
like that you know it's not like that's
what I woke up saying I was going to do
one day it's just that each day as my
life evolves and I continue to meet new
people and collaborate on new projects
and roll out new exciting things like
you mentioned somebody's basement and
your actor NBA these are things that
it's like I didn't these things weren't
in my life a year ago and now I'm going
wow how cool that I live in a place
where we can just say hey let's try it
let's see what happens let's put our
brains together and create something and
people support that I love that I
don't know many other industries where
that is true of the day to day we've
talked about something called a plan Kay
the effort and about that yeah because
you say when you moved out here you had
a plan a which quickly turned into a
plan B and then C and and you worked a
series of survival jobs to kind of carry
you through how did you remain positive
and and still have that strength to
carry on because those jobs can really
beat people down and transition into
that plan k yeah I think the key with
survival jobs and in particular is that
you have to choose a job that doesn't
suck your soul and a lot of people find
that desperation drives them to take on
jobs that that maybe a little soul
sucking and I think you have to do
whatever it takes to prevent yourself
from being in those types of jobs and if
for some reason you have to work a job
like that you have to do whatever it
takes to steel yourself against becoming
bitter because as a creative artist
bitterness enters the room before you do
and that's going to prevent you from
getting the types of jobs that you
actually want if your survival job is
beating you down and making you
resentful and instead if you look at
your survival job as wow this is the
thing that empowers me and enables me to
do this cool acting class or to do this
copy credit meals gig this weekend or
whatever and then just be in a place of
appreciation I think that that is the
first step toward staving off bitter
actor syndrome interesting okay we've
also seen you discuss doers versus
talkers and you say doers usually get to
doing way before anyone has the chance
to reject them but talkers kind of keep
talking and remain bitter yeah expand um
it's interesting because as yeah I think
this may actually go back to some of
that how when I came out here in 93
ignorance is what what trophy ignorance
may not be the right word it was
probably just naivete but it's I think
that having an action plan and doing
research and having a plan before you
jump is is essential absolutely I
wouldn't have written the book that
talks about creating a plan but I also
think there comes a time when you just
have to go do it and you have to try it
and you try it at the right level you
know you get here and you say wow I'm
new
let me do some student films let me do
some low-budget Indies let me do some
non union or copy credit meals let me
let me just go out there and collaborate
and start building some relationships
but the people who sit around and talk
about no I'm not doing anything until
I'm top of show guest star on a network
sitcom I'm like dude you can't enter at
that level you have to work up and you
have to build relationships in order to
make that happen and it takes time and
so I hear a lot of people talk about
plans and how they're going to make
things work but they're not out there
hustling they're not creating their own
projects they're not putting up shorts
on youtube or put you know creating
content to show people what they can do
instead they're just making plans and at
the end of the day they wake up their 40
and they're still you know waiting for
their sag card or waiting for their
agent or worse they have an agent and
they're waiting for that person to get
them into rooms rather than realizing
that they're the ones who have to do
that work the agent just closes the deal
and do you think that's fear or ego I
think it's different for everybody I
think for some it's ego I think for some
it's definitely if you're probably for
most it's fear I think I think for some
it can even be like family issues that
they feel beholden to their their family
level of success and it's kind of
terrifying but they moved thousands of
miles away and came out here and so if
they came out here but then still need
their family back home somehow they are
serving that and those roles rather than
coming out here and being hugely
successful in being the types of you
know butterflies that we know they can
be if they would just break out of the
cocoon to use that analogy I just I
think there are so many different
reasons that somebody could be blocked
from success it's a mean that's my
therapy exist I guess I love it haha we
had a question from our listener
nathaniel j brown he's an actor and he
says what do you look for on an actor's
resume what's the one thing that should
stick out the most and he says what are
you looking at what's the tool and actor
has to have is that the real um well
let's look at when I would be looking at
an actress resume by the time i'm
looking at a resume I've already decided
that an actor is the right type based on
his or her head shot for the role on
what
he or she is submitted so I've put out a
break down the type description is there
an actor is submitted I look at their
head shot and I know that they're the
right type for the role so they stay in
the mix then I'll open and take a look
at their resume and this is all
happening electronically this is this is
not hard copy headshots and resumes
we're talking about this is all online
through actors access or breakdown
services and I'll take a look at their
credits to see if they are at the level
this role requires if it's a lead role
or if they're going to be playing
opposite you know let's say I cast an
Oscar winner in a low-budget indie film
yay me um yeah it's happened it's
awesome we get somebody who's going to
be in every scene with that actor I need
to see certain level of credits on that
that other actors resume to be sure that
they can handle sharing the screen with
an actor that way i would also take a
look at their demo reel to be sure that
they have the kind of roll experience
that we're looking at is you know do
they have this genre experience in their
in their demo reel can i actually see
them doing this sort of work I don't
know that there's any one thing that
turns my head on a resume more than
anything else there can be times i'm
looking for something very specific like
special skills or a certain amount of
improv training or there are certain
coaches that if i see their name in the
training section I go oh I know what
kind of training they've been going
through and that means something to me
but it's it's also just a certain level
of our they add a supporting level as an
actor or are they ready to take on a
first lead you know there are even
little nitpicky things like if I take a
look at their resume and see principal
misspelled I i wonder how intelligent
the person might be it i know homonyms
are tough i get it but it's it's always
interesting to me when someone
misspelled is a coach's name or they
misspelled a director's name and the end
they're sort of treating it casually and
it it just makes me wonder do they
approach their acting casually and so
that seems super nit picky but it's
something that certainly will draw my
attention in the wrong way that's good
enough much of their work right even and
I know so many super talented
individuals who have invested years of
working on their craft they audition
relentlessly they have TV credits they
have film credits
yet that big break has not come for them
they haven't gotten to the point where
they can sustain themselves as actors
maybe they've had a good year here and
there but it's not lasting what do you
tell someone like that um patients but
at that point they've already probably
exhausted their patients you know if
they really have been at it that long I
you know it's it's tough when someone's
been working at it a long time and
hasn't had the career traction that they
anticipated they would have you know my
first tip would be you know don't
anticipate how it's going to look you
know because if you go into it saying
I'm going to give it a year I know so
many people will move to LA and say okay
I'm going to give it a year I might dude
you can't even learn the freeways in a
year you can't you just can't set
yourself up like that and this is such a
complicated and complex system here and
so for people to instead say well I'm
moving to LA because that's where I'm
going to live and I'm going to pursue
work there and it may be at the
low-budget indie level it may be Studio
features yay me it may be web TV it may
be top a show guest on a top Network
sitcom again yay me so you can't know
though where your success is going to
happen and one of my my favorite things
to do is talk with actors who are self
producers people who create their own
content because those are folks I find
that if things are go slowly for them
aren't going as they anticipated when
they moved here they're just taking the
reins of their career and saying you
know what screw this i'm going to show
them what I can do and they're creating
content that then happens to go viral
and they don't go start out with a plan
like let that let's have this go viral
because you can't plan for that what
they do is create something to be a
showcase for what they are capable of
doing figure put this on a real get this
in front of agents and managers may be
in front of casting this would be good
for me and then it turns out to be
something that people really get excited
about and they pass it around the share
button it's a very powerful tool and it
gets people excited and then networks
are watching production companies are
watching agents and managers are
watching there's someone on payroll at
every production company and every major
agency whose job it is to watch the
internet
and there's a reason for that it's
because there's money to be made there
and it's because that's how people are
starting to inform us who's ready for
their big break so I guess the advice I
would give would be you know have you
exhausted everything truly or have you
only tried what what used to be the way
that you would get cast which is you
move to LA you get your headshots stay
in classes you get an agent or manager
get your sag card they submit when they
call and say you have an audition you go
that's the old way that way is now
secondary to creating your own content
and popping on the radar of the buyers
and when you say that someone looks
ready what's that vibe that someone
gives off when they walk into a room
because you've written about that before
that you're kind of your vibe your aura
whatever you want to call it announces
who you are before you you even open
your mouth what is that vibe that the
actor gives off that they're ready I
think it's more that they're not giving
off the stench of desperation it's sort
of what it's like dating you know you
know the date the date with the person
who just kind of leans in a little too
much and who's just a little too eager
and you're like man it's not going to
happen you know it's in and could have
everything going for him but if it's if
it's just he's too eager you kind of
feel uncomfortable on his behalf it's
it's a lot like that the especially this
comes back to the having the survival
job that doesn't beat you down because
if you show up to an audition feeling
like I have to book this because if I
don't I can't pay rent we feel that and
we feel anxious for you remember we're
all sensitive craters everybody who's in
this industry we're all artists were all
creatives even if our job is to
negotiate major deals we still have that
side of us that is creative or we
wouldn't be drawn to this industry and
so because of that we're very sensitive
to those vibes and when somebody walks
into the room feeling hungry and
desperate and needy for it we may not
even understand that that's where that's
coming from but we just feel this sense
of man there's tension there's something
there that is making me uncomfortable
and instead you need to make us feel
like hey don't worry I got this let me
show you how I act and then by us
feeling that you have that confidence
and don't mistake confidence for being
cocky but when you come in with that
confidence
and the ability to then show us the work
and make us comfortable that you got it
covered then you feel like a solution to
a problem which is all casting is
finding a solution to a problem I mean
what was great about bonnie is she so
generous with their information you know
and doing the research on this show so
if anyone listening if you're coming
across Bonnie for the first time she's
pretty extraordinary at getting back to
people and being open so highly
recommend you find her on facebook that
you find her on Twitter and get to know
her a little bit more let's go a little
bit deeper Bonnie what what can you tell
us what what frustrates you about actors
um gosh yeah ones who don't take
advantage of the resources that are out
there especially with the internet
especially with with social networking
and how many of us are making ourselves
accessible to actors and and giving free
information you know I've been writing
my column at show facts for over six
years that's you know over six years of
weekly archived free and searchable
columns I mean hundreds of thousands of
words right there for you free don't
even have to buy my book by my book
great awesome yay me but you don't have
to and someone came on my facebook wall
on my fan page just I think yesterday
day before and said you know I'm an
actor and I'm 29 and I'm desperate and I
really want to make it I'm like boy
there nothing that turns a casting
director on more than just coming right
out and saying you're desperate but he
talked about how he had no one to help
push him and he just need to be seen and
that's all he needed so see me how do i
how do i get seen and I said darlin
first thing you need to do is go and I
gave him a link and I sent him to the
the first column I send everybody to if
they reach out like that and say go read
that and read the links of everything
that I linked up in that column and read
everything it's going take you a few
days but when you're done come back with
follow-up questions I'll be glad to help
he came back within two hours and said
yeah yeah I read all that I need someone
to discover me I need someone to see me
and I'm like well I can't force you to
read like I the informations there there
are lots of ways you can help yourself
but there are people who nlj uses its
like the diet industry billions of
dollars every year people are spending
on
whatever the quick fix is no one
actually wants to hear that it takes
hard work and discipline over time and
that's the only thing that works
consistently but it's the same thing
with the entertainment industry you have
to work hard you have to be disciplined
and you have to spend time doing it and
if you do all that and build the
relationships and research and learn who
the players are and put yourself in
front of in your best light doing the
things that you do best in front of the
people who are most likely to buy what
you are selling you will succeed in this
industry but people that want to hear
that they want to hear how can I be on
the next friends today like well I'm not
sure what kind of advice to give to
somebody who comes to me and says I want
to be famous because I really i don't
know that's that's a magic trick that's
that's not but I think when you talk to
most actors and what I really love about
actors in Los Angeles in particular most
of the people I've met really do get
that they could be living their wildest
dreams by being the actor whose name
nobody outside the industry ever really
knows but they get stopped on the street
by people who are like I know you well
you're that guy in that show or I know
you I saw you in that movie with that
other guy what's your name well i know i
love you i don't know who you are but oh
my god i love you but they recognize
your work and they know they enjoy it
there are actors like that who are
making tons of money and never have to
worry about doing anything outside
acting for the rest of their lives but
they're not household names and i think
that things like TMZ and entertainment
tonight and US magazine have sort of
dropped us into a world where we we
champion the celebrity rather than
realizing there are all these supporting
players who really make the films and
the TV shows possible and i think in
factors pay attention to that as an
ambition they're much more likely to
succeed it's a more realistic goal
absolutely love what you're touching on
there
amazing I was gonna jump in there but
she just kept going and I was beautiful
it was beautiful like I'm not even gonna
touch it is it always the most talented
actor who gets the part you know what
what what factors come into play set me
up you know the answer to that question
is no there are many times it's not the
most talented actor who gets the part
and that especially comes into play on
on project that I'm working on the
low-budget Indies where we have to get a
certain number of name actors and I use
the word name actors because the
industry uses the word name actors it's
not mine don't yell at me for using it I
didn't create it yes I know everybody
has a name but if you are called a name
actor you are someone whose name on the
marquee is going to put butts in seats
and on the low-budget Indies in
particular we have to convince our
investors that they're going to earn
their money back in overseas sales and
in distribution and the only way to do
that sometimes is to attach a certain
level of name actor in the project and
so there are a lot of times that a role
will go to somebody who may not be the
most talented because that person helps
bring us name value or it could even be
an actor who's not considered a name
actor but who is coming on as a producer
and brings in money and that person is
going to get an opportunity that someone
who doesn't bring the money would get
there are a lot of factors do you look
like you could be related to the person
you're supposed to be related to so okay
we got someone who's more talented but
when we see her on screen with the woman
who's supposed to play her mother it's
so clear they couldn't possibly be
mother and daughter well then we can't
go with the most talented we have to go
with the most talented who also fits the
bill physically so there are a lot of
factors with that but you knew that
let's go back to the actor's voice which
is truly a phenomenal column I mean if
anyone on you know you can actually see
it for free you don't have to be on
actors access or show factors you can
actually just log in for free and one
post that truly stuck out to me was
a one on high self-esteem low ego and
you say that this is a necessary
component for someone in any part of
this industry you touch on that yeah um
the you have to be low ego in order to
handle the ego crushing blows that
sometimes come with a career in this
industry but you have to have high
self-esteem because you have to be
believable that you can you have to be
able to believe rather that you can
succeed you have to have sort of a dual
mindset about this you have to trust
that you are the most talented most
exceptional most amazing most wonderful
badass that's ever walked in front of
these people because you need that
confidence to drive you you also have to
not have your ego tied up in whether you
succeed or fail and I guess I really
shouldn't even say succeed or fail
because to me it's whether you get that
job or not because that's not successor
failure that's all the pursuit you got
to be down with the pursuit in this
industry because that's what you're
going to be doing most of all is
pursuing and if you can get down with
the pursuit then you can have career
longevity and you'll get parts and you
won't get parts and it's not successor
failure it's not that you did a good job
or a bad job it's just the way it goes
and sometimes you weren't the right fit
and sometimes you were and sometimes you
were the right fit and then the money
fell out and you didn't get to do the
job anyway you know there are all sorts
of factors and if your egos tied up in
that that leads to better actor syndrome
if instead your self-esteem is very high
and your ego is on the low side you can
bounce back from that stuff very easily
when it doesn't go the right way but
also always believed that will go the
right way so I'm curious what is the
cure for bitter actor syndrome once you
cross that line can you go back lots of
spa days massages lots of retreat type
behavior meditation saging out you bet
you bet read outliers start to finish
dude I'll be there there are a whole lot
of ways that you can I think reboot I I
call it a soul reboot and sometimes you
just need that
and and I think that artists in
particular need to watch out for
becoming bitter and when that when they
come anywhere close to it do whatever it
takes you know go fishing take Tate
you'll hang up the sign you know don't
check your email don't tweet don't just
disconnect from everybody if that's what
it takes and really get clear again on
why you're pursuing this because i think
if you come back to the why like why are
you in this i think that fixes a lot and
if your motives are to become famous ok
that's all right I don't you know
necessarily align with that one but I
think as long as you whoever you are are
working on a path that you're aligned
with everything goes ok and what
bitterness comes from is feeling so off
path from from where your heart and soul
truly is to get a little whoo whoo wow I
like it ok love it absolutely absolutely
love it i'm trying to gather my thoughts
here i'm told i'm totally good mama
thought like a mohawk typical but um I
can't help but thinking of when I took
acting class so I'm thinking of my guy
Michael will he was my acting teacher
and you know and he would talk about you
know casting directors and casting
assistant you know I here's what he
would recommend he would recommend
becoming friendly with casting
assistance you know number one is
because casting directors are very tough
to pin down there they're extremely busy
number two is that the assistants would
one day be casting directors themselves
and this kind of touches on the fact of
you have to be thinking long term I love
how your component of like you're not
just going to come out here and it's
going to mass gap and you have to be
thinking long term you have to think
like I'm here to have a career in this
business my question to you are there
any actors you form relationships with
early on in your career that you still
cast today absolutely yeah there there
are people who read for me on the very
first feature film I cast which would
have been the summer of two thousand
three it was a
twenty-five-thousand-dollar budget indie
film the SAG experimental contract a
contract so bad it doesn't exist anymore
it was just tiny tiny tiny budget film
and
as an actor who auditioned for me there
are several actors actually who
auditioned for me on that when I was you
know who the heck are you brand new
casting director you know most of them
had known me as a writer for backstage
Wes where they knew me as an actor who
was out auditioning with them five years
earlier and here i am putting out a
breakdown and the fact that they're like
well what the hell will go came in and
auditioned for me then they get offers
from me now on the two million dollar
budget Indies and you know and i'm still
at the beginning of my game i've only
been casting seven and a half years so
you know i'm still new it is well how
you say that seven half years i'm still
new I hope hope everyone's taking note
of that yeah you bet well especially if
you move here and figure you got 50
years ahead of you in this business in
this place yeah you bet I'm a fraction
of the way through my casting career and
and learning something new on every
project which I love because I'm
collaborating with people who have a
different set of problems at a different
budget level or a different confidence
of financing level you know all the
things that go with indie film but the
people who showed up for me on those
early early projects and did a great job
and didn't treat it like some crappy low
budget budget in different independent
film but instead treated it like hey
this is a great opportunity and let me
show Bonnie what I can do those are the
people that I still love the most and
bring in as often as I can now you bet
we have this question in from Terry Reid
any insight on the process of getting
name actors here we go with the name
actors interested on a project so you
can get financed ears and or producer
studios directors interested would be
appreciated beyond the obvious know
someone part of the equation yeah and
actually I wouldn't even go with the
know someone as being the first the
first thing that wasn't even the first
thing that would pop it in my mind so
I'm glad that's obvious to some but to
me the most obvious is the material has
to be amazing the script has to be
fantastic and I am not kidding and I
know everybody thinks their baby is
perfect believe me there are a lot of
bad scripts out there I've read most of
them it is my casting philosophy this is
what I said this when when I started
casting in 2003 I said I'm going to use
this business model amazing projects
with rock star kroos go after actors who
aren't in it for the money
that's it that's the formula for cricket
feet casting and that's how I've built
my business and I am so proud that I
chose that business model seven and a
half years ago because I really have a
track record of work that I'm very proud
of and it's because every script that I
put in front of agents and managers is a
pleasure to read it's clean it's tight
it's formatted correctly it doesn't have
sub text written in the dialogue it
doesn't have subtext written in the
stage directions it doesn't have
incorrect your or its or any of those
crazy making things and I know that
again the sounds really nitpicky but on
a film that's maybe only two million
dollars if I'm sending that script out
to CAA I have to promise that agent who
covers me look it's not gonna suck even
if it's not your favorite genre it's
going to be a great read and anything
that would take somebody out of the
moment so misspellings or formatting
errors or just newbie mistakes that you
know people screenwriters just
overlooked is is something that has to
be taken out before it goes in front of
the agents and managers because we're
hoping that they're going to give us
access to their highest level name
talent on a project that doesn't have a
lot of money or may have none of its
funding and I can't build a reputation
as a casting director putting something
in front of somebody that I'm not proud
of and so that that to me is the most
obvious thing that has to be that the
script has to be amazing the team has to
have a track record if there are some
short films they've done together
they've got festival cred because they
want some awards on a short before and
then this is their first feature I work
with a lot of first-time feature
directors who have a great short that
did very well on the festival circuit or
even made it through the Academy
qualifying process I think that's
awesome because if I have something I
can show them and say hey look while
we're putting this offer in front of
your name actor here let me show you the
the stuff that these guys were able to
do on five thousand dollars and this
time we got two million and think oh wow
that's really good and the scripts tight
and the offer is good you have to have
enough money to make an offer and I'm
and I specialize in in not having to pay
or play offers I'm very lucky with that
because I work on such strong material
but you do have to have enough money
that if they say yes you're ready to
escrow that so that you can get them
attached and get that letter of intent
and then take that to the investors and
get them to open their wallets wider I
know this system inside and out it is a
dance it is a lot about reputation it's
a lot about trust and for me to be able
to say to agents trust me this is a
great project starts with a fantastic
script and a great crew because I want
thank you notes from everybody on that
set I want everybody to say these are
the best actors we've ever worked with
and I want the actors to thank me for
putting them with that crew and I get
that really important it's all about the
building of the relationships especially
the low budget level because nobody's in
it for the money mm-hmm well on this
similar vein we have a question that
came in from Conrad Steve I believe he's
listening hello Conrad and he says I do
have a question in regards to ask asking
acting talent to defer their pay on my
projects since I am uncomfortable to
make such requests how best to approach
this thorny issue when I am directing
micro budget productions regardless if i
am in canada or elsewhere okay well that
starts with your team you hire a casting
director and that's someone you pay you
don't ask that person to defer her
payments because she's going to be
working really hard and getting you a
lot of people attached who can make your
film happen and so that's that's someone
who you don't scrimp on the money for
the casting director but because what
that does is then that allows the
casting director to lean on
relationships that already exist to get
talent to work below scale or for
deferred payments depending on the
contract that's in place and so then the
director isn't the one making the
uncomfortable request it's the casting
directors job and the casting directors
dealing with agents and it's their job
they're used to having these
conversations and they have shorthand so
you trust that you have surrounded
yourself with a team who can make these
requests less unpleasant you know let's
go back to our good actors for a second
if you had a pep talk with an actor
before their audition coach Gillespie I
was going to say ha how would you coach
them I mean what would you say to them
oh it's the shortest it's the shortest
speech ever have fun don't suck that's
it that is all the advice I give to
actors before an audition because you
all have your own processes you all have
your own way
way of approaching material and I don't
ever want to micromanage the process of
how an actor gets to a certain place
with a role or with certain material
that's not my job but what I do want to
do is just remind them we want to see
people who are having fun and we expect
that you don't suck so if you accomplish
those two goals then that's that's all
we need and it may not be that we can
cast you in this project right now but
you've come in showing us that you have
a good time you've made some strong
choices you understand material and
you're good actor will call you in again
and then that's talking about the
relationship building process the most
essential part so we always focus on
what actors are doing wrong in an
audition what mistakes have you seen
directors make demonic Aston I've seen
directors who don't really know how to
talk with actors you know people who did
really well in film school learning
about all the technical components but
never had a class in how to have a
conversation with a creative critter
with a soft underbelly you know and I
think that'd be a really good class in
film school and I have seen that offered
then it's being offered more and more
which is at the top of the interview
where I talked about my book being a
part of the the film school curriculum
lately that's that's where that's coming
in but I think that the the biggest
mistake I've seen a directors make in
sessions with actors would have to be
just not being able to communicate or
articulate exactly what it is they want
from them in a language that the actors
can understand but then again that's
part of my job is to then sort of
translate and say okay here's what he's
actually looking for and help the actor
get there or give them words that may be
the director isn't coming up with but
that I know he means because we've had
six weeks of conversations about how
this role should look we've had a few
guests here um Bonnie that have is what
you know it may error I should say not
not not as meant that many guests have
as much going on their lives as you do
and we've touched on a little bit here I
want to do something sort of fun here
yeah I want to try this can you do some
small favor and can you just kind of
highlight just a handful of the ventures
that you're you're involved with right
now sure okay there's the casting got a
couple projects going on right now that
I'm very excited about we attached Peter
Fonda in a long tomorrow which is a
two-million-dollar indie film that will
be shooting later this year in
well it was going to be South Carolina
but it's now looking like Connecticut
because they've got some incentive so we
will see where that goes yeah that's in
the air right now but I think the thing
I'm probably most excited about right
this instant is your actor MBA because
at your actor nba.com we're going to
launch content tomorrow so right now if
you go to that URL there's nothing you
can go to our fanpage but until tomorrow
there there is no content and as of
tomorrow there will be lots of content
and more and more and more this is going
to be a course an online course
video-based with experts from all sorts
of areas of the industry we have agents
managers casting execs showrunners
directors actors you'd recognize image
consultants money management experts all
sorts of branding people who are going
to meet with us on a weekly basis to
talk with actors about how they can
control the business part of their
career and there's nothing like this
that currently exists on the web so I'm
really excited about into collaboration
that I'm a part of with Marcy Lee Roth
who's a casting legend and Mitchell
think who's a wonderful working actor
who also does marketing consultant work
with actors and so I'm real excited
about that because it's launching soon
and I've been putting all my energy into
that somebody's basement is a website
that we launched in May and the idea
behind that is if you get the right
people together creating their own
content like a band in somebody's
basement you can have some really
amazing stuff so rather than
self-producing actors having to have
their work compete with hamster on a
piano at YouTube and try to you know
somehow rise above the millions of
videos that are there it's a place where
each day weekdays we put up another
piece and it is that that is the one
piece that's being showcased on our site
that day and it's all independently
produced content and that's very
exciting very very pleased with that you
know you touched on some good things let
me because you're not because I know you
can keep going to eat when you're
involved in so many projects what I just
had this idea you know let's imagine
that everything you do is sort of piled
together like a like a game of Jenga
okay how many blocks would we be able to
pull away before just at all just comes
collapsing down i mean it is it so vital
for you to have your
hands in so many pots hmm it's
interesting because I I don't see the
configuration as as jang going something
that's going tall and skinny i actually
see it as something that's going very
flat and very wide reaching so i think
because i lay my Jenga tiles out pretty
low to the ground i can have a whole
bunch of them because if you take one
away you're just moving it and putting
it somewhere else it's not the support
for anything else none of the projects
that i work on hinges on the success or
failure of any of the other projects
it's everything is sort of its own thing
one thing I'm ninja good at is
compartmentalizing and it's kind of
terrifying to people who don't have
brains that work like that but I'm
really good at just focusing on here's
the one thing that I'm doing right now
and then when it's time to stop focusing
on that I go and focus on this other
thing and I'm really good at not being
distracted while I'm in that space and
so because of that I don't think that
there's any one thing that the success
of all these projects hinges on other
than you know my ridiculous ability to
not sleep social media how has it
enhanced your career efforts well it's
interesting i think myspace probably did
the most to make a big jump for me with
my column and so i'm stretching back to
like 2006 now I had had found out what
my numbers were on my column and they
were impressive but I said you know what
we can do better and so I joined myspace
and I started promoting my column at
myspace and tripled my readership within
three months and I said yeah that's
right that's what we got to do we got to
put the word out because people once
they find it will read it but there
there was no real advertising for it so
I said well just I'll use social
networking to make that happen so that's
where I notice the biggest impact back
in 2006-2007 what facebook has done is
allow me to get to know some folks
better before I meet them for the first
time and I found that to be very
interesting in casting situations
because I'll meet someone maybe even at
a networking function not even in a
casting session but I've known them
through their comments and their status
updates on facebook or on twitter and
then find okay they're not they're not a
whacker they're actually pretty normal
okay cool
I all right you're not creepy at all and
then I meet in person go no not creepy
at all very cool and so it's sort of a
nice a nice way to make sure that there
are no blind dates interest as
everything gets vetted a little bit and
you started a blog than two years ago
I've been blogging since 1998 before it
was called blogging oh yeah yeah I had a
my favorite ex boyfriend has a server
private server where he was running
journals for us and then when blogger
launched we all went over to blogger
software and then from there to movable
type and now to WordPress and so that's
that's been going on forever and it
really is just my journaling which is I
always right I always have my mom when I
was growing up and saying my daughter
the writer and I would yell and scream
and stomp my foot say I man dressed
don't call me a writer I thought it was
such an insult and of course later when
I realized wow looking at my tax
statement and how much money I earn as a
writer I go wow mom was right I'm a
writer and of course I knew that long
before I was getting paid to do it but
my mom was right very nice those two
things we knew coming into the show
number one that it was going to be
tremendous and number two that was going
to go by too fast yeah both wings have
happened we should just uh end on a
final note do you have a question for
our audience and if if you do we'd like
to pose it on facebook I would love to
know what you're doing to prepare
yourself for this for actors what you're
doing to prepare yourself for the
opportunity to be seen when you have to
tape yourself that's something that is a
trend that's happening more and more I'm
seeing actors getting an opportunity to
put themselves on tape and sort of doing
pre reads before we're inviting people
into the session room and I think as
constraints of budget come we're going
to see more and more of that and as
technology gets cheaper for actors to
buy you know the for the cameras to my
favorite audition I saw an actor shoot
from his cell phone camera and so I know
it's possible to do I'm I'm noticing now
a difference in the actors who are ready
to embrace that and shoot their own
stuff and they're putting themselves on
tape for everything versus those who are
like that's not my job I'm not going to
do that and so I want to know what are
you doing to prepare yourself so that
you're ready for that next wave of the
casting process
okay we've been speaking with author
producer and casting director Bonnie
Gillespie to find out more on Bonnie
well there's many places you can go to
cricket feet com Twitter at Bonnie
Gillespie facebook.com slash cricket
feet you can also go to spy notebook org
slash Bonnie and also your actor NBA
somebody's basement and Hollywood happy
hour com very nice Thank You Bonnie
thank you thanks for having me this has
been a blast guys